I'm just hanging out doing normal  everyday stuff cheese and crackers I  have a problem with the US government  well good thing you came to me the one  nice and normal guy in the CIA yeah  let's give you more screen time than you  probably deserve thank you so it turns  out your country's been committing war  crimes on my nation kidnapping civilians  overthrowing democratically elected  leaders and plotting our downfall for  decades this clearly violates the Geneva  conventions and demonstrates that oh  shoot out a fair point for sure for sure  but but I just heard that a bad guy  wants to kill you see the bad guy has  the same problems with us that you do  but they are and I cannot stress this  enough  bad can you just help us out this one  last time please pretty please please  please fine but we need to talk about  this other stuff later oh yeah yeah for  sure for sure we will  we will